eric holder merci eric mendez alors
j'explique aux téléspectateurs c'est le
chauffeur de salle mais non alors quand
tu dis il ya eric mendez qui va venir je
t'attends pas du tout à son physique à
propre sang et apprend que ça que ça
bonnes chaussures avec mendes là mais ça
y est tu t'attends pas du tout s'est tu
te prends des cours de salsa avec eric
mendez s'il vous plaît et en fait et tu
vois arriver cette personne qui a étudié
dans sa loge à la salsa c'est vrai tu
danses à peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
à
hahaha
[Applaudissements]
matrix ya apprécié qu est ce qu on a dit
ok mais pas tout seul
tu es vachement bien elles sont arrivées
à temps m'a dit est ce que pour la
relègue le frère on dirait le mec en
direction d'arles le guen est arrivé
c'est le sonia riehl en on est tous bien
on est frais il arrive mon frère on
dirait qu'il a fait huit heures de
voiture
non mais ça ouais attention a passé à
peine après la porte sans ego les frères
mais kuyt à la piscine est la suisse ou
quoi c'est donne à fond qu'il donna
n'entend pas autant d'en bas on n'a pas
de micros alors je vais te donner le
camp micro jamais c'est vrai que les
chauffeurs de salle heures alors il
tonne d'acier vous présenter sur les
gens qui font l'émission as ari gold à
vienne elle a bien près de moi alors
eric mendez non mais sans rire et qui
est chauffeur de salle savez comme un
don qui travaille pour la 9 ans n'ont
concédé qu'un but depuis france 4 c'est
ouf
c'est incroyable dix neuf ans ah ouais
cool c'est un plaisir de très fines
vraie fashion week est très bon aussi
fidèle avec les bons non mais c'est vrai
oui eric ne lâcherai jamais bah si c'est
gentil sera avec nous pour les 10 ans
l'an prochain ah bah j'espère oui là on
avait je peux te le confirme et tout de
suite c'est parti c'est fait
[Applaudissements]
ça serait si on a dix ans 10%
ah ouais c'est pas une augmentation
c'est pas de allez c'est parti
[Applaudissements]